Okay.
We're going to cover one last thing with exponents, and it has to do with
squares. In particular, I mean squaring numbers, like 4 squared and 5 squared.
Specifically, I want to know if 4 squared plus 5 squared is the same thing as
the quantity of 4 plus 5 squared. I'm going to draw some squares to help us out.
This square's going to have sides of 4, and this square's going to have sides of
5. This square is going to have sides of 4 plus 5, or 9. But I'm going to split
it up so that way I can see the side with 4 and then 5. It will look like this.
This side is going to be 4 and this side is going to be 5. I've kind of
exaggerated it, but it's okay. This side is also going to be 4 and this side is
going to be 5.